usted lo hace sonar bastante simple por
la realidad es mucho más compleja que
esa esa es una compañía inmensa con
miles de personas que trabajan en ella
con kilómetros y kilómetros de vía
ferroviaria con estaciones de tren y
todo tiene que trabajar a la perfección
para que usted cumpla su objetivo qué
tanto conocía ustedes esta empresa y que
tanto estaban preparados para una
situación como esta
teníamos otra opción
los rusos vinieron y empezaron a matar a
mi gente
teníamos que pararnos y hacer nuestro
trabajo de manera correcta No pensé en
que si aprendía rápido que se aprendía
despacio en este caso usted va y hace lo
que tiene que hacer
Y qué hizo hicimos evacuaciones
cuatro millones de personas evacuadas
dentro del país
incluido un millón de niños
evacuamos 120 mil mascotas incluido un
cocodrilo
evacuamos 600.000 personas desde Ucrania
los países vecinos
al interior cientos de miles de kilos de
ayuda humanitaria
hicimos que mi país viera como los
cargamentos de exportaciones crecían
Porque esa es la sangre para la economía
Así que hicimos todo lo que teníamos que
hacer